je sais l'implication du gouvernement
même si elle est récente en faveur de la
relance de la filière nucléaire de notre
pays mais cela passe par des moyens à
consolider pour notre outil industriel
qui doit accomplir cette ce programme
nucléaire à savoir EDF qui doit faire
face à une dette colossale de 64
milliards d'euros qui doit faire face à
un mur d'investissement dans les années
à venir et cela l'ucrémont déclarait
lui-même que ce ne sera pas possible si
le prix de la reine reste fixé à 42
euros du magawater
Agnès panure une hachée reconnaissait
elle-même que le prix de production par
EDF était aux alentours de 58 euros donc
on va bien qu'il y a un delta qui qui
est important et je demande au
gouvernement un minimum de cohérence
vous savez qu'il est encore temps de
prendre les mesures nécessaires d'une
part pour ne plus bafouer les décisions
du Parlement de piétiner ses décisions
vous avez actuellement je vous le
rappelle un véhicule législatif à
l'Assemblée nationale qui vous permet de
les faire de le faire je vous invite à
vous en saisir merci merci
[Applaudissements]
avec les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement merci madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen
de la promotion de loi visant adapter la
défense extérieure contre l'incendie à
la réalité des territoires ruraux d'un
séance est suspend